hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and today we
are looking at
palm is that you honey yes
walk the wait what happens
in fashion what do you walk the runway
the runway oh no
hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand lime waifu and i'm
embarrassed
let's move into the review now episode
124 and today the power of emotions and
love saved the day
and a charged-up crying broken-hearted
teenager so let's talk about this dress
palm did the bugs teach you fashon since
when does magical hair shape itself into
a balloon gown
and how is that protective underneath
the balloon
gown get balloon pants maybe balloon
pants next time what's with the hat they
are not outside why does she need to
look like a fashionista or more
specifically why does she need to look
like he was mom
in order to deflect attacks
i don't know what's happening today help
i'll come back to the emotion of this
episode i'll come back to the fact that
there are huge and far-ranging
consequences to the fact that the human
experiment failed
right now we're talking fashion and the
people want to know who designed
your outfit what we do know now is that
all these ant clothes are literally made
from their skin
or carapace or unknow whatever like
their hair
ultimately i'm personally both a fan and
not at all a fan of palm's clothing
largely because i'm not a fan of putting
anyone in heels for combat situations
all that aside kilowatt is casually
telling palm where gon is seems very out
of character for him
he knew for a fact that things had
changed and while she might remember him
it was sloppy having him begin to tell
her
that information like just tell her that
information
i understand a lot has happened in the
last 20 or so minutes but i was
surprised
when he actually said something even
though we went into his mind to pass
through the information
to date kilwa has largely been someone
who tends to try to remain safe rather
than sorry and for him to drop that
yes he's in an emotional state and yes
there's a lot going
on and yes it's palm who gone seems to
have a genuine
interest in but it's still kiwa acting
in a very un-kilowa
fashion if only the plug socket he
dangerously stuck his fingers in that
you should never do
had recharged his strategic mind kilwa
has always been one of those characters
who is highly strategically minded but
then rarely strategically acting and
it's one of the things that i like about
him
he knows what he should do he's great at
assessing situations and
great at knowing how best to advise
people and he has all this knowledge
but when it comes to application of said
knowledge or the manipulation of that
knowledge his conclusions can sometimes
be a
wonky this i find is one of tagashi's
best
characters and best ways of showing
character
because it's so so relatable and so
very specific it's a perfect
representation of high intelligence low
wisdom
while gone exhibits high charisma but
low intelligence and average wisdom
sometimes gone rolls high on wisdom or
intelligence and that can be surprising
but it's
fairly rare kiwa finally breaking was
beautiful
and i i it was just
he deserved the rush of emotions he felt
they were well past you for our little
murder boy that behavior is why we love
shows about young people
young people are socially allowed to
have these lapses in judgment and
awareness in a way
that adults just aren't it's important
for example that lyorio is a teenager
like the rest or we'd have some serious
questions to ask about his behaviour and
choices
palm reads in the context of this show
as a young adult which is why some of
her behaviors are really problematic but
equally it means socially we're allowed
to fully sexualize her within the
context of this show
not that we should but that it's
socially allowed we talked about this a
little when she and gone went on a date
but i think it's important here because
it brings us to the human experiment
pito did on her
they make it so clear that there are
hundreds of people standing outside
waiting to be turned into an army but
that those with access to men and those
with
some emotional cognizance or memories
will be more powerful fighters is it the
nen in this case that helps palm break
out of the mental prison she's in or is
it the fact that her brain isn't
actually fully developed into an adult
one
emotions are such powerful things and
when we're younger they basically run
our lives
look at gone in the last episode look at
kiwa in this one
look at meruem's stillness and palms
fury look at the emotions of all these
characters then compare them all to the
penguin guy way back when who we know
came from an older adult compared to
natero
the flavor of the emotion is different
when it's in a younger person
it's more immediate more powerful more
extreme that the experiment didn't work
isn't because pito isn't strong enough i
don't think or that the
experiment simply couldn't work i think
it didn't work because
emotions run hotter the younger you are
all we've seen for the last few episodes
have been hot and cold emotions
especially in our younger characters be
that through their physical behavior or
through their use of men
even a calgo i have no idea what his
prior life was like but
his emotions strike me as a late teen's
emotions
hot and powerful in their fury but
burning out fast especially looking at
that switch from the feeling of
helplessness and weakness to ultimate
strength when something he was
passionate about was in danger
impulse basically i'm saying this entire
arc is based on teenage behavior through
all the main characters the ants and the
humans the ants they're all
at the moment roughly the same age which
is a wonderful development given we've
seen them grow as a civilization
almost in real time well for me anyway
it's been weeks and months and months
and weeks next we get to see
whether the emotions have sped up the
fall of humanity or slow it down
because tinkly poof saw it all happen i
guess we'll find out how well things go
in
episode 125 having had his beliefs
validated in the previous episode kilwa
knows now that he is the one for gone
gone's chosen date told him so
you know the date who decided to hunt
him down and kill him when he told her
that he wanted to do the mature thing
and not make a commitment to a
relationship he wasn't able to keep yeah
huh
meanwhile mary's playing games with an
atero while naterro plays out his
magical girl fantasy go while it's
really impressive that natero is
smacking meroem around
i find it very telling that all those
throwing hands are actually not killing
him
i'm not sure nataro's trying to or maybe
he is
but he's failing very significantly he
took us through a thought process of
why he would wait for people to attack
and it seemed almost due to boredom
in the same way that meroem practiced
strategy on a board it very much feels
as though natero practiced strategy as
an early combatant to see
all the possible attacks people could
throw at him or ways they could try to
defeat him
at least that would be sound reasoning
and that's the reasoning i'm going with
because it makes the most sense like you
just let people attack you until
they do something different like people
are pretty consistent once you know
their behaviors i mean that's the whole
point of
mirom's like thing with kamuki right
like you just out
learn them anyway when he stopped
allowing them to strike first the
flashback seemed to have another level
of boredom to it one that suggested he
wanted to make his way through people
who would waste his time
and skip to those who would be worth it
but of course that's to no avail
he's really really powerful so he's
potentially never been able to use his
several armed spider jointed
golden deity of gratitude his
thankfulness seems throughout the
episode to skip from gratitude that he
has the skills to
gratitude that there's someone he gets
to use them on might actually be worth
the time and energy
the music of the latter part of this
episode is bold and brave and operatic
but more than anything
it is adult continuing the conversation
we had last episode
i had last episode despite meruem being
the youngest of the ants
baby leftover aunt aside he has so often
shown the maturity of an adult that it's
hard to characterize him as anything
else other than an adult the stillness
of thought and mind of meruem as he's
hurtling through the air at a
hand-slapped velocity is
very composed compared to literally
anything to do with knuckle or gone
and so the operatic tone to the tomb
natera slaps him into fits
beautifully well as both a metaphor and
a characterization without kamugi around
there's a world
weariness to this incredibly young
character and despite just saying the
arc is a teen drama this side to the
proceedings is very much the adults
talking
in theory without killing each other
comparatively anywhere poof is
there is a young teen jealousy element
involved
little to no music means that the focus
is on words and by reducing the colors
down to just purple with no real tone
we did focus very sharply on those words
and on poof's actions
which is to say that we all know that
they all know
that there is descent in the ranks we
now explicitly know that
pito doesn't trust yupi or pouf to look
after kamugi which means they're going
to be looking for someone else to look
after her who they'll choose i'm not
sure but as i've said before pito to me
is one of the most goal orientated
characters
so i could see them just you know
choosing knuckle and knuckle would do it
because knuckles knuckle
pito is as i said one of the most goal
orientated characters and that might be
because of the narrator helping us to
understand them but that's interesting
in itself
the narration of pito's thoughts and
motivations specifically always seemed
to help convey the story rather than
feeling lazy by dropping visual frames
when the narrator is used in this way
i'm always pleased frankly
and it's fascinating seeing which minds
the narrator chooses to go into and why
and what information is divulged when it
does we had so much stillness in the
first half of the episode we have
yet to be in god's mind not a new thing
but definitely worth noting because
there's also no
steam no steam none whatever's happening
in gon's mind may as well be
only what's happening in the room
because we don't know how much he knows
just what the others think he knows it's
entirely possible that he already knows
by knuckles existence that yupi is still
alive he knows that poof is still alive
so
that means that there may have been a
number of deaths or things going wrong
and he has no idea at present
where kilwa is unless he does and they
have like a soul link or something i
don't know
i don't know whether he would break or
has already broken is sort of the
question now because the steam the smile
the warm melty eyes
those were all hallmarks of gone as a
character for the last
however many arcs it has been three four
those arcs
we haven't seen that in at least 10
episodes or so
not since he sat down to deal with pito
what is the mark of a broken character i
guess
is it when they're beaten into the
ground is it in their final moments of
life
is it when they're crying on the floor
before an enemy potentially kills them
or is it when they're sat in front of
someone they don't even know if they
want to fight but they have so much rage
they can't control it anymore
despite all my misunderstanding and
understanding and annoyance
of god's intelligence being mocked by
having steam pour out of him the fact
that there is none here suggests there
is instead serious pressure buildup that
is gonna have to be released at some
point and on that cheery note
that's it from me if you enjoyed this
whatever this
was oh click here here and here and here
there's a bell there's other videos
there's
food off off camera and his screen
microphone somewhere over there is food
have a lovely week
and i'll see you next time